you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross vice
president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact in 2014 Alexis Martin was
considered the smartest toddler in the
world when doctors tested her
intelligence at 3:00 she scored a
hundred and sixty IQ points by the way
the average adult has an IQ of about 100
her incredible intelligence was first
noticed by her parents when had one she
began to perfectly recite her bedtime
story from the night before by two
alexis was able to read fluently and at
3 she had taught herself to speak
Spanish from a language app downloaded
on the family iPad she also memorized
every US state including their capitals
as well as learning all of the different
parts of the human body all of this
before her 4th birthday at 3:00 alexis
became the youngest person to ever join
the prestigious mesa organization where
to be a member you need to score within
the upper 2% of the general population
on an approved IQ test
she was recorded as having an IQ that
was 99.9 percent higher than anyone else
of her age group an incredible
achievement for someone of any age let
alone a preschooler King Solomon in the
Bible would have also broken all records
for having a high IQ when the young king
took the place of his famous father
David he felt inadequate he told the
Lord I'm a little child I do not know
how to go out or come in first Kings
chapter 3 verse 7 when God asked Solomon
what he would like the king responded
give to your servant and
understanding heart to judge your people
God was so pleased with Solomon's
request that he gave him not only great
wisdom but riches and honor as well
did you know friends that God wants to
give you a special supernatural wisdom
stay tuned for more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evenings
program call 888-814-3923 God says for
63 72 97 I'd also like to greet our
friends who are joining us on Facebook
across the country and around the world
you can also call in with your Bible
question you want to call the same
number eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven well before we get
to the questions this evening it's
always a good idea to start our program
with prayer so let's do that right now
dear father we are indeed grateful for
the opportunity that we have to open up
your word and study together and we ask
your blessing upon this program be with
those who are listening in Jesus name
Amen
I open the program this evening by
sharing an amazing fact about an
incredible person
Alexis Martin who has a very high IQ
just amazing what she was able to
memorize even as a toddler and of course
the Bible speaks of King Solomon as
having great wisdom being was the wisest
man the Bible says who ever lived now
God wants each of us to have wisdom a
special kind of wisdom not necessarily a
wisdom that will help us score high on
an IQ test but rather it is a wisdom to
determine and know God's will James
chapter 1 verse 5 says if anyone of you
lacks wisdom let him ask of God who
gives to all liberally and without
reproach and it shall be given to him
without a doubt the greatest wisdom that
anyone can have is the wisdom of know
God knowing his will for our lives and
yes God will reveal his will his plan to
those who ask the Bible says we need to
ask now the next verse which is James
chapter 1 verse 6 says that the one
seeking wisdom needs to ask in faith and
so we ought to ask God in faith
believing that he hears and that he
answers our prayer and ultimately we
want to know what is God's will for my
life we have a free book we'd like to
send all of those who are listening
those in North America it is a book
written by pastor that batchly entitled
determining the will of God and that is
a free offer this evening all you'll
have to do is call our resource phone
line that's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven again that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
you can ask for the book called
determining the will of God if you're
listening on Facebook or outside of
North America on the internet and you'd
like to get a copy of the book or you'll
need to do is go to the website just
amazing facts o RG or calm and you can
download and read it for free the book
determining the will of God and again
that is the greatest wisdom that anyone
can have well friends the phone lines
are open good time to pick up your phone
give us a call the number here to the
studio with your Bible question is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven and our first caller that we have
this evening is David listening from
Wyoming David welcome to the program
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my call you're welcome
and your question this evening my
question had to do with is there a
biblical reference for the act of
cremation there's not a command in the
Bible that says whether someone can't be
cremated we do have an example in the
Old Testament of Jonathan who was a
godly man who was killed in battle and
his body was somewhat mutilated by the
enemy and some of his men came and took
his body and they cremated it and then
they buried him but the tradition that
you often find in the Bible both in the
old and the new testament was that a
burial but again there's nothing wrong
with being cremated because
you have so many people even in New
Testament times many Christians that
gave their life many of which were
burned at the stake for their faith in
God and in the resurrection God is gonna
resurrect them so he's not all right he
doesn't need any leftovers from this
body to recreate the Bible says these
mortals must put on immortality so
typically the tradition of the Bible was
that a burial the reason being is the
Christian believed in the resurrection
at the second coming of Christ and as a
demonstration of their faith they would
often bury their dead believing that
when Christ comes again they will be
resurrected but the Bible doesn't say
that you can't be cremated nor does it
say that you have to be buried in order
to be resurrected when Jesus comes does
that help okay yeah I appreciate that
all right thanks for calling David we
appreciate you call our next hole that
we have is let's see we have somebody
who is calling from Pennsylvania
Maria welcome to the program hi thank
you Pastor Ross hi and your question is
evening my question is in reference to
Revelation chapter 1 verse 7 where it
states that Christ is coming in the
clouds and every eye shall see him
including those that pierced him and I'm
a little confused because the ones that
pierced him are the wicked dead and so
according to what I've read the wicked
dead are going to be resurrected in the
second resurrection so how is it that
they're going to see him when he comes
and the first resurrection is going to
be when the dead in Christ are going to
be resurrected and the ones that are
alive in Christ are going to be raised
up to meet him in the clouds right and I
had questioned someone about that and
they said well there's going to be a
special resurrection for them and I'm
thinking well then that means there's
three resurrections and those are going
to suffer three deaths and that would
mean that Jesus is not merciful because
he's resurrecting them and then they
resurrected today destroying them again
right
well let me share let me share a little
bit about that from the Bible hopefully
to help you write Revelation 1:7 for
those who are listening it says behold
it comes to the clouds is clearly
talking about the second coming every
eye will see him when he comes again
then it says and those who pierced him
and all the tribes the earth shall mourn
because of him what about this group
that pierced Jesus this is referring to
those leadership at the time of Christ's
crucifixion the Jewish leadership the
Sanhedrin the high priests as well as
some of the leading Roman probably
Pilate could be amongst that group or
the soldiers they played a leading role
in the crucifixion of Jesus they are
according to this verse resurrected to
see Jesus come the second time now that
doesn't mean they saved but they are
resurrected why are they resurrected
well we have a clue in Matthew chapter
26 verse 64 it's an important verse
Matthew 26 64 this is where Jesus is
standing and he is being accused by the
high priest a me standing in front of
the Sanhedrin and all kinds of
accusations will be made against Christ
and they couldn't really find witnesses
to agree Jesus didn't say anything he
just stood quietly and finally the high
priest said to Jesus I journey by the
Most High tell us are you the Christ and
then Jesus could remain silent no longer
and he responded and this is what he
said Matthew chapter 26 verse 64 jesus
said to him it is as you said
nevertheless I say to you hereafter you
shall see the Son of man sitting at the
right hand of power coming in the clouds
of heaven so the high priest who was
accusing Jesus and Jesus didn't respond
finally when the high priest said I
journey by the Most High are you the
Christ Jesus could remain silent no
longer he said if you want proof you
will see me coming in the clouds of
glory so there are those who are
resurrected this is a small group
resurrected when Jesus comes because
they asked for proof Jesus will give
them proof now they are destroyed along
with the rest of the wicked with the
brightness of Christ's coming and then
there is the final judgment that takes
place at the end of the thousand years
so in that sense they do die three times
they died once and then they are
resurrected at the second coming they
die again by the brightness of his
coming
and then the third death which occurs at
the end of the thousand years but that's
just a small group the vast majority of
the wicked they die the second death at
the end of the one thousand years after
the great white throne judgment does
that help okay write down the verse it's
a Matthew chapter 26 verse 64 okay okay
thank you so much you have a good night
all right thanks for calling our next
caller that we have is Matthew Matthew
is listening in Sacramento Matthew
welcome to the program hi Matthew you on
the air
yes you might want to turn your radio
down in the background a little bit I
can hear an echo here I can you you yep
you're good and your question this
evening my question is is where was the
Holy Spirit in the Old Testament Saints
and what was the difference in the way
he worked in their life and the way he
worked in the New Testament Saints okay
good question
well the Holy Spirit is throughout the
Old Testament matter of fact you read
about the Holy Spirit in the very first
chapter when it says when God created
the earth darkness was on the form of
the deep and the Spirit of God moved
upon the face of the waters we find
Elijah
asking for a double portion of the
spirit that was upon Elijah and he
received the double portion of the Holy
Spirit we have an example of Saul who
was filled with the Holy Spirit and he
actually prophesied so you know the
prophets of course in the Old Testament
were filled with the Holy Spirit you got
great prophets like Isaiah and Jeremiah
you got Daniel and others they were
without a doubt inspired you have John
the Baptist the Bible says that he would
be filled with the Spirit of God from
his birth so without a doubt you do find
the Holy Spirit in the Old Testament you
find it in the time of Christ and then
also in the New Testament but there was
to be a special outpouring of the Holy
Spirit upon the apostles to aid them in
their work of taking the gospel to the
world and that you read about in acts
the book of Acts where they were
assembled together in one Accord they
prayed the Holy Spirit came upon them
that were filled with power they were
given supernatural abilities to speak
languages that they hadn't learned and
then the gospel began to spread out from
Jerusalem to Judea to Samaria and then
to the uttermost parts of the world so a
special outpouring of the Holy Spirit
but the only spirit is always been
active in the hearts and the lives of
believers right from the very beginning
right okay well why did you just say
that he had to leave in order for the
confidence or the holy spirit to come
there was a special outpouring of the
holy spirit that God wanted to give that
Christ wanted the disciples to have but
in order for that special gift to come
Christ sacrificed this by the way when
Jesus made this promise this of course
before he ascended to heaven after the
crucifixion in the resurrection when
Jesus ascended to heaven he as our high
priest stood before the Father and it
was through his priestly ministry that
he requested a special outpouring of the
holy spirit upon the disciples so Jesus
says the special outpouring could not
come unless I be or unless I returned to
my father in heaven well Jesus was to
return as our high priest and represent
our need and our requests in a special
sense after his crucifixion and
resurrection and of course as a result
of that outpouring of the Holy Spirit
the gospel into the world but also
remember Jesus prior to the crucifixion
gave His disciples power to perform
miracles to cast out evil spirits and
all of that happened before he ascended
to heaven so the Holy Spirit was still
active before Christ's ascension right
okay well i have i've always often
wondered just what the difference was in
the way that the holy spirit worked in
the old testament saints versus the new
testament saints I mean like you said I
know he's always been there
sure in the Old Testament the Holy
Spirit worked to draw people in faith to
look forward to the coming of the
Messiah the Promised One the Redeemer in
the New Testament the Holy Spirit works
within the heart of the believer to
build our faith in the fact that Jesus
did come as well as team power us to
take that good news to the world so in
the Old Testament the Holy Spirit is
helping people to look forward in the
New Testament it's helping us to look
back and to believe the reality that
Christ has come right okay yeah that
does help shed a little light in on the
way to my perspective of it you know
yeah that's a good question we do have a
book Matthew that you might
interested in or anyone who's listening
it's called life in the spirit talks
about the Holy Spirit
especially the Holy Spirit and the
Christian and we'll be happy to send
that to you Matthew or anyone who calls
and asks call us on our resource phone
line that's 808 three five six seven
four seven and you can just ask for the
book called life in the spirit again
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven the
next caller that we have is Christine
listening I believe in Connecticut
Christine welcome to the program hi
thank you hi thanks for calling and your
question this evening my question is are
we really in the time of revelations and
is everything we're seeing really today
showing us that we are in the time of
revelations my question is really is
this what revelations is sure absolutely
yes the answer is yes now the book of
Revelation covers a long period of time
it begins with the first century
typically the Christian era so begins of
the first century John wrote the book of
Revelation somewhere around 90 AD he was
the last of the Twelve Apostles the
others that already died he was on the
island of the Patmos an old man by this
time and he received these visions he
wrote them down and that's what the book
of Revelation is so revelation traces
the experience during the Christian era
of God's people and so it begins of the
first century goes all the way through
to the second coming of Christ and then
even after the second coming of Christ
until in Revelation chapter 21 it talks
about the earth being recreated the
final judgment seeing the earth is
recreated the New Jerusalem comes down
from God out of heaven all of that is
yet in the future so yes we are living
in the book of Revelation if you want to
know where we are a little more
specifically there are three phases we
have seven churches we have seven seals
and we have seven trumpets and each of
these different series of sevens cover
the Christian era we're living in the
last of the seven churches called the
Church of Laodicea or
living in the time period of the sixth
seal which is just before the second
coming of Christ and we living during
the time of the seventh trumpet which
again is right close to the second
coming of Christ so if you look at all
of these different aspects of the book
of Revelation yes without a doubt we are
living in what we call the last days
you're living close to the end of time
okay and should we be afraid in any way
of these last days or no well you know
the Bible tells us that if we have faith
in God if we're a believer in Christ we
don't have to fear the Bible tells us
perfect love casts out fear so there are
things happening in our world that is
alarming we have fires we have natural
disasters we have conflict between
nations and people and all of these are
signs of the end the Bible speaks of it
Revelation speaks of it and yet when we
see these things as believers we we need
not despair rather we should have faith
in Jesus he's promised to take care of
us as I believe we have nothing to fear
he will see us through the Bible tells
us that God will protect us he will send
these angels to watch over us so as a
believer know we need not fear rather we
should look up in faith believing wow
Jesus is coming soon and there should be
an urgency to share this good news with
the world Jesus is coming okay thank you
all right thanks for calling Christine
appreciate it
next caller that we have is Jerry and
listening in Kansas
hi Jerry welcome to Bible answers live
thank you yes and I've always heard that
when Christ returns we're gonna meet up
in the clouds and he won't touch the
ground and if you hear stories of he's
down at the lake baptizing or he's doing
miracles in the mountains and you got to
come see him just beware that that's not
in Christ and I've heard the best place
yes tonight that he doesn't hiss be
you're gonna touch mountain oh okay
when does that happen well first of all
if you're looking at Matthew 24 Jesus
gives signs of his second coming one of
the things he says in Matthew 24 is do
not be deceived there will be many false
christs that will come and they will
even perform miracles and
and do signs and wonders jesus said if
somebody says to you look Christ is in
the desert don't go out or if is in a
secret chamber don't don't go there when
Jesus comes according to Revelation 1:7
every eye will see him it'll be a most
glorious event Christ comes in the
clouds with all the Angels now when it
comes the second time according to John
chapter 14 if you look from verse 1
through 2 verse 3 when Jesus comes the
second time the righteous will be caught
up to meet Jesus in the air and we will
go with Jesus to heaven
in John 14 one two three Jesus says in
my father's house there are many
mansions I go to prepare a place for you
and when I go I will come again and
receive you unto myself so when Jesus
comes the second time he comes together
the righteous comes together the
believers he takes us back to heaven we
spend a thousand years in heaven in
Revelation chapter 20 talks about this
then at the end of the thousand years
the New Jerusalem comes down from God
out of heaven all the redeemed during
the city Jesus is in the city then it is
that he sits his foot upon the Mount of
Olives you read about this in Zechariah
and the mountain opens up and forms a
great valley and the New Jerusalem comes
to rest in the valley all the wicked are
then resurrected at the end of the
thousand years for the great white
throne judgment in Revelation 20 at the
end of that judgment the wicked mount
their attack upon the New Jerusalem fire
comes and devours them then God creates
a new heavens and a new earth so for the
second coming Jesus does not touch the
earth the righteous are caught up to
meet him in the air but at the third
coming then it is that Jesus will sit
his foot upon the Mount of Olives it'll
open up and form a great valley and the
New Jerusalem will come to rest right
okay and that clears it I thought he
said the second coming he was touching
the amount of all of the night I got
confused that clarifies it thank you
very much yep that's the third coming
yep we've got three comings of Jesus in
the Bible the first coming was as a baby
the second coming is as king in the
clouds of glory and the third coming he
comes as judge and so we have the 1st
2nd and 3rd coming we do have a study
guide Jerry that you might be interest
you know anyone who's listening it's
called a thousand years of peace and you
can actually call and ask for that we'll
be happy to send it to you or anyone
wanting to learn more about this 1000
year time period the number to call is
808 three five six seven four seven and
you can ask for the study guide called a
thousand years of peace our next caller
that we have is chase listening from
Houston Texas
chase welcome to the program thank you
for having me here welcome and your
question this evening yes so I'm curious
about Revelation 16 the seven bowls of
God's wrath when does when does this
happened in relation to Jesus second
coming and how long does it last okay
good question the seven last plagues are
poured out just before Jesus comes there
is an event that occurs just prior to
the start of the seven last plagues of
the seven bowls and that is what we call
the close of probation the close of
probation is described in Daniel chapter
12 verse 1 through 2 verse 3 it says at
that time Michael shall stand up the
Great Prince who stands watch over the
sons of thy people and there will be a
time of trouble worse than the world has
ever seen and then in Revelation chapter
22 when that time comes Jesus says he
that's holy let him be holy still he
that's filthy let him be filthy still so
probation closes at that point the
righteous are protected after probation
closes while this time of trouble occurs
or the seven last plagues are poured out
so the seven last plagues fall after
probation closes God's people are
protected during that time period you
can also read in Psalms and ninety-one I
believe where it says no plague will
come nigh thy dwelling so God's gonna
take care of these people at the end of
this seven last plagues then Jesus comes
matter of fact the seventh plague is
associated with the actual second coming
of Jesus how long will it be from the
first plague to the seventh plague the
Bible speaks of a power known as Babylon
in Revelation chapter 17 it represents
this religious political power in the
last days that wars against God's people
and it says that her plague shall come
in one
day now 1 prophetic day according to the
Old Testament and also Daniel revelation
1 prophetic day is about a year so a
number of Bible scholars feel that after
probation closes in the 7 last plagues
begin to fall it's roughly the time
period of about a year until Jesus comes
ok
does that help thank you yes it does all
right very good thank you for your call
we appreciate it
our next caller that we have is Thomas
listening in Toronto Canada Thomas
welcome to the program oh great thank
you maybe I can yes ok great
yeah my question um it's in regards to
you know Jesus paying God and there's
something the question Mary had to offer
he's offering for giving birth to Jesus
right yes and of course there's a
certain group of people that believe
Mary never sinned but most products is
don't believe it and so Mary was a
sinner but she didn't commit any sin
inverse because God said for them to go
create and bring forth lights and
obviously bringing forth Jesus was part
of God's plan too so my question would
be it says sin is a transgression of the
law but it doesn't casing is the only
transgression of the law
because they also did sin offering for a
person who is not precious person
testified body sure so basically what
I'm saying is sin can be non guilty like
our sin nature and also guilty detection
yeah well let me follow let me respond
to that yes we're all born with an
inclination toward self or selfishness
that's selfishness is manifest in
disobedience to God's commandments so we
recognize not only the acts of sin that
we might commit but we also recognize
the motive behind the son that's why
when Jesus says if you're angry with
your brother without a cause you're
guilty of committing murder now of
course it's not exactly the same as
taking the life of somebody else but the
principle is there in other words God
wants the change of heart and the New
Covenant promise is a change of heart
but God says I'll put a new spirit
within you I'll write my laws upon your
heart so all of us have sinned and come
short
glory of God and we all in need of
cleansing we all in need of that new
heart experience Jesus said in John
chapter 3 except you be born again he
cannot enter into the kingdom of heaven
so there has to be a change of heart and
we speak of that as being conversion
well friends you can hear the music in
the background it's not the end of the
program we're just taking a quick break
and we'll be right back with more
questions
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website at amazing facts fo r g
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven a mutiny that moved
to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong if you've missed any of
our amazing facts programs visit our
website at amazing facts org there
you'll find an archive of all our
television and radio programs including
amazing facts presents one location so
many possibilities amazing facts org
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 Coley's andrew
listening in tennessee andrew welcome to
the program hello find
on the air hello pastor Ross thank you
for what you guys do uh so my question
is regarding mr. William Miller in the
early or the in the middle 1800s
he used the Book of Daniel to forecast
the fall of the Ottoman Empire and he
got it right which everybody was like
really fascinated with and then he used
also the Book of Daniel to prophesy the
cleansing of the sanctuary which at the
time he thought was the second coming of
Christ
now I remember hearing pastor Doug say
something about him saying that it would
be it would be the 1844 but then there
was a problem with the calendar is that
correct
well sort of let me let me back up and
give a little bit of the background for
I hear is there might not be familiar
with this back in the early 1800s around
1830 a little before that a Baptist
preacher by the name of William Miller
based upon his study of the Book of
Daniel came to the conclusion that 18
I'm gonna put you on on just Mutua for a
second Andrew we get a little background
noise the preacher by the name of
William Miller based on his study of the
Book of Daniel and particularly Daniel 8
verse 14 came to the conclusion that
something significant was going to
happen in 1844 Merrifield he recognized
this as being the second coming of
Christ and the verse that was key to
this was Daniel 8:14 where it says for
2300 days then the sanctuary shall be
cleansed
now William Ella recognized the
principle in the Bible that one
prophetic day is equal to one literal
year and we see that in the Old
Testament in different places we also
see that principle in the New Testament
and so with some further study he began
to realize that the 2300 days of Daniel
18 814 actually represent 2300 years he
also based upon reading in Daniel 9
realized that this 2300 year time period
begins with the decree to restore and
rebuild Jerusalem which occurred in 457
BC
so based on that he did the math and the
number ended up around 1843 1844
initially was 1843 because they didn't
account for the year or they put in a
year zero there but when you go from BC
to AD it goes one BC and then directly
180 there's no zero yeah but they
thought that the cleansing of the
sanctuary that was spoken of here in
Daniel 8:14 was the earth and the
cleansing of the earth would occur in
Jesus comes the second time now they got
the time period right but what they got
wrong was the event
this wasn't a cleansing of the earth by
fire meaning the second coming of Christ
but rather there was a special work of
cleansing that Jesus was going to do in
the earth amongst believers and we began
to see tremendous truths being brought
to light around 1844 there was a great
religious awakening and revival that
occurred not only in North America but
also in other parts of the world and
there was a renewed interest in studying
the prophecies of the Bible so they
didn't get the event correct but they
got the timing correct and also if you
look in Revelation there are some time
periods that actually refers to the fall
of the Ottoman Empire under the various
trumpets and based on their reckoning of
time those events did occur does that
help a little later oh yes
actually yes that actually helps a lot
but the question that I had was
regarding she got the Ottoman Empire
fall correctly yes and I'm not saying
that he didn't get the 1844 date correct
what I was wondering is if they
accounted for the year 0 prior to him
forecasting the fall of the Ottoman
Empire okay yeah the 2300 days was
already pretty much established at least
it was presented prior to further study
of the fall of the Ottoman Empire but in
1843 when things didn't occur as they
thought it would occur and B people
began to question their interpretation
of the time period then it was it wasn't
actually William Miller what another
Miller eyed believer by the name of
Josiah Lynch who really was the one that
studied the trumpets and brought to
light the idea of the Ottoman Empire
surrendering to the ally
powell's or at least the powers of
Europe the Protestant powers and that
did occur as predicted and so that gave
sort of evidence to the principle of one
prophetic day is equal to one the trio
okay okay it was just about the Year
Zero or the Gregorian calendar yeah no I
didn't affect anything we related to the
Gregorian carrying the only thing is
that the Year Zero when you go from BC
to 80 is not there it just goes one BC
to 180 thank you very very much you're
welcome thanks for calling Andrew next
caller that we have is Robert listening
from college place Washington Robert
welcome to the program ho pastor rod hi
Robert I just have a hopefully a pretty
easy question
Hebrews four eight I believe yes because
it talks about there being another day
of rest and I'm I'm guessing that's not
Sunday but I thought I'd ask speaking of
another day it says yeah let me read it
for those who are listening y'all think
you're referring to Hebrews 4 verse 8
for if Joshua had given them rest then
he would not afterwards the spoken of
another day is that what you're
referring yes uh-huh ok yes the context
of the verse just to kind of give you a
little bit of the the background here
what Paul he's doing we'll believe Paul
was the writer of Hebrew Hebrews he is
drawing an analogy of the children of
Israel going up and entering into the
Promised Land and he equates entering
into the promised land
as entering into rest and he uses that
as a symbol of the spiritual rest that
believers can have in Christ so after
talking about how that the children of
Israel had come up to the Jordan River
about ready to go into Canaan but
because of unbelief they were unable to
enter into the rest of the promised land
they ended up wandering in the
wilderness for forty years but then Paul
also makes the analogy that I wasn't a
physical rest that God was truly wanting
to give Israel but it was a spiritual
rest found in Christ and when he says
talks about another day he's referring
to a quote that David makes in Psalms
and of course David lived a long time
after Israel and entered into the
promised
Lane and he says it wasn't just their
entry into the promised land that was
the rest that God wanted to give them
but there was another rest that he
wanted to give believers in Christ he
also brings an analogy with the
seventh-day Sabbath as being a symbol of
that rest as well so that's what he
means when he says another day it's not
some separate day but he's actually
referring to is you'll read talks about
the seventh day of the week the Sabbath
has been a rest for the people of God so
another day is is the spiritual rest
you're saying yes the other day that
he's referring to is in other words it
says if Joshua who led the children of
Israel into the Promised Land if he
would have given them the rest the
spiritual rest that God really wanted
them to have then David wouldn't have
talked about another day for rest for
the believer so he's saying there is a
broader rest that God wanted these
people to have a spiritual rest and he
connects that spiritual rest with the
seventh-day Sabbath okay very good thank
you good question all right appreciate
it
next caller that we have is Edward and
he's listening in Bronx New York it
would welcome to the program thank you I
have been having problems with Luke 13
verses 1 through 5 okay and I was
thinking I'm thinking it's a hard saying
of Christ and also ease and repent lest
you perish and I'm thinking even if you
repent that doesn't guarantee that
something bad will not befall you so
what's going on in those verses alright
good question I mean let me give a
little over the background of the verses
here for those who are listening
there was an occurred there was an
actual historical occurrence that took
place at the time of Jesus where there
was some of the Galileans who Pilate had
put to death and the disciples asked
Jesus about this and they asked with
these greatest sinners than the rest
that this happened to them and then
Jesus responded and said well this is
verse 2 do you suppose that those
galilaeans were worse sinners than all
the other Galileans because they
suffered such things then he says in
verse 3 I tell you no but unless you
repent you will also likewise perish and
then he gives another illustration
eighteen men upon whom a wall fell when
they were building this tower and they
were killed so the Jews believed that if
something bad happened to you it was
because you were a great sinner Jesus
one of the disciples to realize that
what happens in this life yes there
might be trials and difficulties and
even the righteous or good people suffer
what Jesus wanted people to realize is
that if they had faith in him if they
believed in him even if something bad
were to happen to them here they have
hope of eternal life in Christ Jesus was
always trying to direct people's
attention to eternal life
that's why Jesus said he who believes in
Me shall not perish but have life and
people thought well what does he mean I
mean obviously people are still dying
well Jesus was talking about eternal
death often Jesus spoke of this physical
death has been asleep and then at the
second coming you know the dead are
resurrected the righteous dead are
resurrected and they're taken to heaven
so Jesus was helping the disciples to
understand that just because something
bad happened to a person it doesn't mean
that they're a great sinner that's what
they were taught by the religious
leaders I mean you have examples in the
Bible of righteous people that suffered
you have Joel the whole book here is a
righteous man that suffers terribly
Jesus was saying even if you do suffer
there is hope you will have eternal life
if you believe in him
does that help Edward yeah it's a great
deal thank you so much I have more
clarity on those verses now all right
well thanks for calling we appreciate it
our next caller that we have is Sandra
listening from New York Sandra welcome
to the program yes thank you so much
my question is there are seven plagues
and they found in the Book of
Revelations I believe yes chapter
sixteen and exactly what keywords do I
look out for to describe those seven
last plagues all right are you wondering
how you can find to find those plagues
in the Bible yes yes I turn to the Book
of Revelations alright go to Revelation
chapter 16 and verse it starts
in verse one but the first plague is in
verse two and it talks about a terrible
soul that comes upon the people that
have the mark of the beast the second
plague is the sea turns to blood the
third plague the waters meaning the
streams the rivers they turn to blood
the fourth plague is an intense heat
talks about men being scorched with
intense heat the fifth plague is
darkness that comes upon the seat of the
Beast
and then the sixth plague is what's
called the drying up of the river
Euphrates now there's symbolic aspects
to that plague meaning the support
that's given to the spiritual political
power in the last days called Babylon
the support that people give begins to
dry up as they realize they've been
deceived and then the seventh plague is
a great earthquake and that really
occurs when Jesus comes the second time
so you'll read all about that in
Revelation chapter 16 okay I just wanted
to make sure the key words I thank you
so much I really appreciate you taking
the time to explain it to me well thanks
for calling we appreciate that Sandra
next caller that we have is Nancy
listening from Cleveland Ohio Nancy
welcome to the program thank you I'm
very very glad I got true I'm glad you
were able to get through thanks to your
patience
yes so my question was our church is
going in depth through the book of John
okay and in early John it talks about
when John the Baptist baptized Jesus and
some of his disciples began to follow
Jesus that's the first group of
disciples why didn't John the Baptist
follow Jesus as a disciple well you know
that's a good question I think first of
all if you read the story of John the
Baptist and Jesus they were cousins but
they grew up separate from each other
Jesus grew up in Nazareth which is in
the area of Galilee and John grew up in
the wilderness closer to Judea which is
where he ended up baptizing on the
Jordan which is closer to Jerusalem so
they grew up in separate places they
didn't have any contact with each other
during those thirty years before you
know Christ was baptized and John the
Baptist began to
region probably the reason for that is
that nobody could say that the two of
them were working together or had come
up with this thing but they saw what
happened to John they saw when Jesus was
baptized and they heard the preaching of
Jesus oh why didn't John follow Jesus
well John himself said I am the lesser
light pointing to the greater light so
John realized that he was the one who
was to come before Jesus and prepare the
way for Christ and then he was to give
way to Jesus and allow Jesus to be the
one that draws the people to himself and
I think John felt that his mission would
be accomplished if he could draw
people's attention to Christ which he
did he did have some of his disciples
follow but there was still a work that
John was doing even after Jesus was
baptized and Jesus began to preach John
continued for some time after that still
preaching repentance and baptizing
people and pointing people to Jesus so
he still had a ministry that he needed
to fulfill yeah I just never understood
why he didn't stop his ministry and just
follow Jesus but I guess there's really
nothing in the Bible to say you know
like he said maybe he was just trying to
pull back and point and just stuff in
them in the background exactly he he was
very popular John the Baptist was very
powerful preacher and he drew large
crowds of people there was a little bit
of controversy that developed between
John's disciples and Christ's disciples
with reference to baptism some of the
disciples of Jesus started to baptize
later on and there was a little bit of
conflict and so Jesus withdrew and went
up to Galilee it probably wouldn't have
been a good idea for John and Jesus to
try and work together just because of
the ministry and the focus of their
ministry and you know God worked it out
that John was to prepare the way and
Herald the coming of Jesus and then kind
of step back and let Jesus take the lead
yes absolutely and of course he was
faithful oh yeah yeah it just you know I
was telling your assistant when I was on
hold
um you know going back to the book of
John again what an amazing book our
church is really going in depth to it
and I'm catching so much
rakaat before yeah just wonderful oh
it's a great book well one of the
favorite gospel writers is john and of
course he also wrote revelation which is
a great book to study too and just
really great thanks for your call nancy
we appreciate it thank you so much next
call is Roger and he's listening in
colorado roger welcome to the program
thank you for having me pastor yes
thanks your call okay I did a question
rich man and Lazarus
some people are telling me that is
literal okay and I'm saying wait a
second if the bosom of the who is the
bosom a ring yeah that would have to be
extremely large exactly it is not right
well let me say just a few things about
that you find that in Luke chapter 16
he's where you get the parable of the
rich man and Lazarus incidentally it's
in a list of other parables that pretty
much everyone recognizes as being
parables in the parable Jesus teaches a
very important principle you have a
beggar whose name is Lazarus and then
you have a very wealthy man we don't
have his name but he is a Jew the beggar
would in essence be a Gentile and the
beggar is lying at the rich man's gate
and the rich man ignores him and won't
even give him a little morsel of bread
but then in the story both men died and
the beggar is the one that ends up being
rewarded whereas the rich man he suffers
and so the rich man says well why don't
you know can you just put a drop of
water on my tongue and of course the
response comes back from Abraham and
again Abraham is symbolic and Abraham
says you know I can't there's a great
gulf fixed and so on the rich man says
well I have these brothers I five out of
the brothers if someone were to rise
from the dead and tell them then they
will repent and then the message comes
back and says they have Moses and the
prophets if they don't believe them they
won't believe even if someone is raised
from the dead now that's the point in
the peril of the rich man and Lazarus
the rich man represents the Jewish
nation in particular the religious
leaders the Jewish religious leaders
the beggar represents the Gentiles the
Jews had the wealth of the Word of God
they had Moses and the prophets and
ripped yet they hoarded it to themselves
and they refused to believe Jesus now
what's amazing about this parable is
that the beggars name is Lazarus and
Jesus says they won't believe even if
Lazarus was raised from the dead well
there was someone who was raised from
the dead whose name was Lazarus and
still the religious leaders refused to
believe by the way Jesus told a parable
a few days before he resurrected Lazarus
so that's the reason why we have a name
associated with this parable I thank you
very much pastor alright great question
thanks for calling Roger we appreciate
that our next caller that we have is I
think it's Linda calling from let's see
where did she go Linda Middletown
Connecticut is that where it is yes hi
welcome to the program hi
my question is where will there be free
will free choice in heaven yes
absolutely love is eternal the Bible
says God is love so he always has been
he always will be and in order for there
to be true love there has to be freedom
so God has created all intelligent
beings with the freedom of choice he
created his angels with the freedom of
choice and Lucifer chose to rebel
against God he could have chosen to love
God but he chose to rebel against God
and of course each of us have the choice
we can choose to believe in Christ or we
can choose to reject him throughout all
eternity our love will continue to grow
as we continually choose Jesus and we'll
be doing that throughout eternity not
that anyone will want to choose sin
because we've been on an earth and we've
seen the consequences of sin and
rebellion
so throughout all eternity they won't
ever arise rebellion and sin but we'll
still have the freedom to choose Jesus
and we will will be choosing Jesus
throughout all eternity okay thank you
so much
all right good question thanks for
calling next caller next caller that we
have is
let's see Jane calling from Michigan
Jane welcome to the program yes good
evening pastor Roth yes hi hi my
question is that I have some friends of
mine who claim that they believe that
Mary asked Jesus to perform his first
miracle at the wedding feast of Cana
turning the water into wine they say
that it was Mary's idea to tell Jesus to
turn the water into wine and my feeling
I believe is that according to Scripture
it says that Jesus instructed the
disciples to fill the jars with water
that it was his idea to turn water into
wine and my friends insisted that it was
Mary's idea and and they also claimed
they also claimed that Mary had no sin
she was just she was sinless and I don't
know that the Bible says that Mary was
similar yeah well let me address that
first of all the last question first no
Mary was not sunless she needed a savior
the Bible says all have sinned and come
short of the glory of God there's only
one person that has lived a perfect life
and that is Jesus Mary needed Jesus to
save her now with reference to the first
miracle he performed about turning water
into wine you read about this in John
chapter 1 there is this wedding in Cana
of Galilee and it appears from the
context of the verse that Mary was at
the wedding and she seemed to have some
role in helping to prepare it was most
likely a family member an acquaintance
of Mary and Jesus because Jesus was
invited to the wedding
Mary was probably helping with the food
or helping in the preparations and
apparently they ran out of wine or grape
juice and this would have been a big
embarrassment to the family if they
would have run out you know the marriage
family the ones getting married if they
would have run out of grape juice or
wine at the wedding
and so according to verse 3 it says Mary
came to Jesus and said they have no wine
now we don't know exactly what Mary had
in mind when she told Jesus
she was probably hoping that Jesus would
help somehow
and then in Christ's response to her
Jesus says woman what does your concern
have to do with me mine are E's not yet
come now it appears that Mary was hoping
Jesus might proclaim himself as the
Messiah maybe that would involve doing a
miracle we're not quite sure but Jesus
said to Mary ma an hour is not yet come
meaning the time has not come for me to
proclaim myself as the Messiah
nevertheless Jesus recognized the need
and he told the servants to go fill up
the water jars with water and then take
out some of the water and give it to the
governor of the feast the miracle
occurred and yes the water became pure
grape juice and I'm sure Mary was amazed
and delighted that that took place so
Mary came to Jesus with the problem but
Jesus directed the servants in what to
do right okay
all right yeah that's what I had
believed in the scripture as well it was
Jesus
yeah idea by the way by the way there
was one other if you look at that Jesus
said ma now reasoned like you had come
here we have it in the beginning of John
but it's not until the Upper Room where
Jesus meets with his disciples this is
just before his betrayal and before the
crucifixion then jesus said these
disciples mine how he's now come so it's
kind of interesting that Jesus looked at
his hour is really being his betrayal
his crucifixion and then of course his
resurrection his sacrifice that he was
going to provide for those who believed
in him Jesus saw that as the great hour
or the purpose of his coming where is
Mary probably along with a number of the
other you know Jews at the time they
were looking for a temporal Kingdom and
they wanted Jesus to proclaim himself as
a king over the Jews maybe lead a
rebellion against the Romans and
establish you know the Jew or Israel is
a great Kingdom a great nation but of
course Christ's purpose in coming the
first time wasn't
to establish a literal Kingdom but he
was to establish a spiritual Kingdom in
the hearts and the lives of those who
believed in him and the first miracle
that Jesus performed is a good
illustration of his mission he came to
turn the water into wine he came to
provide a sacrifice to shed his blood so
that we might be saved so we can become
citizens of the kingdom thanks for your
call Jane we appreciate that and friends
you can hear the music playing in the
background if it didn't get to your
question this evening let me encourage
you to call next week and we'll try and
take as many Bible questions as we can
until then
god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
want to know God's plan for our world
and solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 805 three eight seven
two seven five okay friends let's start
with the basics we know we're here but
we're not here for very long so the most
important thing would be if we could
learn during this life how to live
forever this is the central focus of
amazing facts there's a lot of wonderful
things that Christian ministries do I
believe in Christian education but if
the school's lose the message of
salvation you end up with more educated
sinners I think it's very important for
us to build churches but if the churches
lose the message of salvation they just
become buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
Friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven and God bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers did
you know that Noah was present at the
birth of Abraham okay maybe he wasn't in
the room but he was alive and probably
telling stories about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of Revelation Bible
history calm is a free resource where
you can explore major Bible events and
characters enhance your knowledge of the
Bible and draw closer to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History com4
life-changing Christian resources this
@af bookstore calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWE
in sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at
[Music]